[Music]
this is the story of a plant
but not just any plum it is the story of
a plant that long long ago once rules
the world
a plant that today is the very last of
its kind it's this plant behind me
encephalitis would be on Eve would be
I'd the short I've been looking after it
for over 20 years it was named for
British botanist John medley woods who
in 1895 discovered it growing on the
hillsides on the coast of South Africa
strange handsome plants caught his eye
and he carefully removed a small portion
of it and had it shipped all the way to
London to here Kew Gardens where he's
been the last 117 years but this history
goes much much further back you see
Entwistle offers woody I is what is
known as a sonic aid and sauna coat have
been around for 300 million years as the
millennion rolled on sonic heads
flourished providing shade for
triceratop approach for pterodactyls and
a tasty snack for brontosaurus League at
one point during the Jurassic psyche
heads made up 20% of all the plants on
earth and covered every corner of the
globe but the good times couldn't last
forever the dinosaurs went extinct ice
ages came and went
new modern plants like conifers and
fruit trees started pushing cycads out
and the once proud population of a woody
eyes were reduced and reduced and
reduced until there was possibly only
one left one single solitary II would
die
growing quietly on a hillside which
brings us right back to John medley wood
at the time he had no way of knowing
just how rare his discovery was but
expedition after expedition in search of
more woody I have proved fruitless you
see psychos are delicious meaning you
need separate male and female plants to
create a new one and this one happens to
be a male a true lonely bachelor if a
female mate cannot be found it really
will be the last of its kind to this day
researchers are still looking after all
it's a big world and might just be a
charm
in the meantime it will have me to keep
him company
when come to Iraq people from outside
the first image they get war bloodshed
kidnapping suicide bombing all this
violence he gets through the media in
the reality is not like that the
beautiful photographer station they
remind you the Garden of Eden my name is
Nabil Moussa and I am a water keeper
water keeper is the voice for rivers our
mission is keeping our waterways
swimmable
fishable drinkable I am the first water
keeper in the Middle East I spent most
of my childhood ride by the river
catching fish playing with frogs and
chasing dragonfly I have some beautiful
memories and I want to bring them back
the problems in an appetiser River dams
urban waste gravel mine oil refinery and
oil wells garbage from picnickers my
current mission is educating people
average raising awareness and water
quality monitoring when the water gets
polluted find out how did that happen
where's the polluter I meet a lot of
people what I'm paddling some people
they are positive some people they are
negative they tell me you are trying to
you know stop all this pollution we've
been having them for for years and years
but our rivers are our lifeline and if
we don't protect them our life is not
going to be safe I want to raise
awareness and tell next generation
action need to be taken I wanted people
to go to nature more appreciate the
water more and to protect it
I have a right to protect the water if
my water
everybody would so I am hopeful
I am hopeful about the future of Iraq
and Kurdistan yes we won't get our
journey takes us to Costa Rica
more specifically sort of y'know to
witness the yearly hatching of baby sea
turtles and meet the people protecting
them we arrive by way of lapa Bona a
small port town with one restaurant and
a pay toilet our boat operator Jairo
guzmán takes us down the lucky river it
is a one hour journey to the island
itself the view is beautiful
nearly all species of sea turtles are
endangered and this island is a
prominent nesting ground for both green
and mother back sea turtles it was here
in 1959 the very first sea turtle
Conservancy was opened by dr. Archie
carp to specifically study green sea
turtles as they were nearly extinct this
was their original base this is Venu
they along with us from the Conservancy
is Hyman Head field director studied
station manager estamos listos quarter
Camille Sylvia outreach coordinator and
their ten research assistants they all
work here to educate the public and
gather data on the current sea turtle
populations on day one we meet in the
middle of the night to count nesting
Turtles and the eggs they lay now let's
go through around dawn we spot a turtle
she's laying her eggs she is one of
36,000 turtles nesting this season on
the beach each turtle will lay around
110 eggs in two months they will hatch
we get some sleep and that afternoon we
ask hi mate about the hatching egg one
she says the best time to catch it is
right up done around 5:30 in the morning
that means we have some down time on the
island
Debu invites us to his makeshift
office we discussed the vision of the
Conservancy basically we are working
here on the legacy of dr. Archie car he
had this idea of changing the mentality
of the people from harvesting the
turtles for their own consumption and
for making money out of the meat and the
eggs into an eco-tourism based culture
it's a very complex thing to protect the
turtles
on day two the alarm goes off the team
gathers and we head to the beach we are
going to need of your boat
for a while we see nothing and then baby
green sea turtles begin making their way
to the ocean only eighty percent will
make it out of the nest and of those one
in 1000 make it to adulthood
this means that out of nearly 4 million
hatchlings this season only around 3,000
will become adults and the odds are
stacked against them there's more down
time
on our final day day three we go to the
beach to excavate a hatch snapped the
research assistants do this job it is
messy they're counting how many eggs
have hatched in this nest nine did not
make it they'll add this information to
their decades of existing research that
afternoon
Cairo's father Goethe Monsignor picks us
up as we leave towards Garrow I can't
help but think of something Sylvia said
back at the base la Isla de Soto eros es
muy importante para nosotros pero
también la stotras son muy importante
strana gente que de Bahia son introduced
Oh muy importante que tenemos que con
sabor eaten a mosquito to help
sea turtles are not gonna stop being
endangered this year and they probably
won't stop being endangered next year
either but it's good to know that there
are people out there working hard to
make change happen
[Music]
white corn is one of our relatives we
feel that she is alive she wants to do
the job that she told our Creator she
would do is to feed our people to
nourish them the work that we do if we
didn't have this we would lose
everything for a few thousand years
Potawatomi people have been incredible
farmers and have grown a lots and lots
of varieties of crops the seed library
is a place where we take crops which are
disappearing rare and endangered
Potawatomi vegetables and we grow them
out and we restore them and put them
back in the hands of native farmers
[Music]
George Martin carries a Potawatomi
tradition of making Dom Nabu or corn
soup in our feed library we have 76
unique varieties of corn each one has
its own cultural identity its own unique
flavor after a while when we stir it
you'll see how tough it gets secures our
corn is a lot different than other corns
which are out there if we didn't have
the feed library his traditional food
might be gone forever
[Music]
women our seed library 80% of the
varieties which we take care of our rare
or nearly extinct some of the varieties
we care for here we're the only place in
the world which have them this one's
going to be a nice one four years ago
when we first got another signal our
white flour corn we only had a half the
canning jar a very small amount of
things we've grown it every year since
and now we have enough that we may have
a hundred bushel full
that's enough that next year we can
plant six or seven acres of justice corn
that's a huge increase it is important
we keep that's what we are sent down
here for to take care of Mother Earth
and all her creations here and that corn
realizes that we're back using it again
that we're going to use it in the feast
makes the corn feel good that we're
being used by our people again dollars
ready to eat
[Music]
there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city people culture
late-night food but there's something
missing it's there but you can't see it
the night sky this is the story about a
small town in Colorado actually two
small towns in Colorado that are devoted
to space west cliff has a population of
564 residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575 this used to be a
mining community and then it evolved
into a railroad community and then into
a ranching community we're always
looking to do something that will bring
people into our community and lately
that seems to be we need to invest in
our sky so they made light pollution
their enemy they darken their towns so
that the night sky could become their
star attraction have you ever seen the
Milky Way that goes from Horizon to
Horizon 88% of the world's population
has never seen the Milky Way it's the
most magnificent thing in the world
that's what we see here but for the
chance to go dark they needed to cover
all of their lights not just street
lamps but the lights outside every house
in ranch near town that wasn't easy this
is a frontier town and I can tell you
frontier people don't like being told
what to do we had to win their hearts
and minds it took ten years they passed
ordinances raised money to cover the
street lights and even build an
observatory and the darker the town
became the more people saw the light
this year the valleys dark sky was
designated as one of the darkest in the
world drawing visitors from all over
okay I need a six-pack well I was really
hoping we'd be able to see Saturn right
now yeah me too that a community would
decide to dim its lights and help
everyone to appreciate the beauty of the
night sky is an amazing thing you come
to a place like this and the stars just
burst and it's remarkable not a lot of
people are lucky enough to see the dark
sky as our ancestor slide and I feel
that we're a very special place to be
able to look at the Stars as people did
thousands of years ago it's a humbling
thing suddenly you realize you can
almost touch it and you're now a part of
the bigger universe and so it's just a
wonderful experience to see the dark
skies and that's what we're trying to
preserve
[Music]
you